OK, let's now get into this crazy situation
that we have to discuss.
The guy who died supposedly from taking Trump's
proposed cure for Corona virus.
Donald Trump has been touting chloroquine
and hydroxy chloroquine as a possible cure
or prevention for Corona virus.
Now, it is true that chloroquine, with and
without a zero Meissen, is being studied in
a mega trial, that the W.H.O. is running as
one of four possible treatments for some people
in some cases.
We just don't know yet.
But this has been amplified by all sorts of
people around Donald Trump and Donald Trump
himself.
And a man has now died after obtaining and
taking what he believed was the medication,
chloroquine, but was actually a fish tank
cleaning product that shares an ingredient
with chloroquine.
So once again, almost all the headlines are
wrong about this.
A whole bunch of people are saying the guy
died from getting the treatment.
Trump suggested that's not true.
The guy didn't take medical chloroquine, which,
of course, you can't just buy is going to
be prescribed by doctors.
It would be done so only in very specific
settings where the patient would be a good
candidate for that.
According to this guy's widow, he kept seeing
Trump.
And people around Trump say this could cure
Corona virus, this could prevent Corona virus.
So the 68 year old went out and got chloroquine
phosphate.
He thought it was the medication, chloroquine.
Of course it wasn't because that medication.
You can't just go out and buy.
The guy went out and got the fish tank cleaner.
It's not a medication.
And the fact that he was able to just go buy
it should have been a signal that it's not
the medication.
The man died and the woman is now in critical
condition.
Now, a bunch of people wrote to me and they
said, you know, we really shouldn't worry
much about this.
This is a sort of Darwin Award situation.
You've got to be really dumb to do something
like this.
Still, we've been saying Trump talking about
chloroquine like it's a game changer can only
cause problems.
It's not going to create any solutions.
And right away, we have one such example.
How insane is it that people are literally
drinking chemicals on Trump's say so out of
confusion?
It's not the chemical Trump suggested, right.
It's reminding me, though, of Jonestown, where
the phrase to drink the Kool-Aid originated
Jim Jones and the Jonestown cult.
It's tragic.
It doesn't get more cultish than this.
Trump says chloroquine.
And people go out and buy something that sounds
like it, drink it.
And one person has already died.
Whatever you think about this guy's intelligence,
it's a truly depressing story.
It's heartbreaking.
And unfortunately, we're going in the direction
of more death, not less death.
And that's very scary, particularly as Donald
Trump, again, is increasingly hinting that
he wants to let it rip to take a page out
of Dr. Anthony Fouty's vocabulary, say just
get back to work.
We've made a calculation that the number of
deaths that that will cause is a fair trade
for whatever economic recovery trump.
Things will happen if he tells people to get
back
to work.